i genuinely am interested in your whole
process well likewise no
i really am a big fan i've really you
know thank you i kind of studied what
you were doing and it
it inspired me very early on as i said
you know because i thought all right
this is a guy who's got balls
and he doesn't mind you know the fact
that you didn't mind breaking the law
or upsetting people was it was kind of i
i followed that rule you know whenever
somebody is trying to shut me down or
say that's illegal
but i know in my career i've done some
things i would go on a red carpet
and interview celebrities and ask them i
would get up at press conferences and
ask
horrible questions you know like
it would take every ounce of my energy
out of me to do it it is people have no
idea how nerve-wracking yes it's
terrifying to
to be the one in the room who and you
don't know what's going to happen i mean
i used to have reporters threatening to
kill me
yeah and i was always shocked because i
was like i just want to make people
laugh
yes exactly well that was the problem
with also doing the leg show and the
movies was that the kind of stakes
became higher so in bruno
you ended up being i ended up being in
situations where
i wouldn't say my life was in threat but
i was in danger of being hospitalized or
you know so
the the end scene in bruno is a cage
fight i don't know if you remember that
yeah
and people were throwing chairs yeah so
i remember when we were planning that
scene and you know
coming back to the original question of
you know you come up with a crazy idea
in the room and it's like you know how
do we make this happen and the idea was
i want to have the love scene where
bruno meets his boyfriend again
and they start kissing in the middle of
a cage fight and bruno's become
this really mature guy called straight
dave and he's pretending not to be gay
you know
and uh one of the greatest scenes ever
and basically
you know i called up the lawyer this the
studio said you can't do it it's illegal
and i said why not and they had their
lawyers on the line they said
you're crossing state lines to have a
riot
and that is a federal offense you know
that that's what they arrested the
chicago seven for
but you know it becomes not just a state
offense so so
you can't do that so i said well let's
see if we can do that let's you know
we're going to do it
right let's work out how the lawyers
told you not to do it you said i'm going
to do it
i said we're going to do it and we're
going to find out a legal way to do it
and doesn't that take a physical
like something out of you to do i mean
because you're nervous as i mean
you went into a cage you're making out
with another guy there's all these
people in the audience who have no idea
yeah we had we were like 300 people sure
and one of the referees said don't worry
you
guys don't don't worry i'll get people
there he basically was a prison warden
and he got 300 ex-cons who'd just come
out
and some of these guys come in they've
got swastikas on their heads right
and i'm there and i know i'm gonna you
know make out with a guy
and start a riot and we had like this
you know this fence around and i had
like security around and i said all
right you know
can anyone climb in and they go don't
worry no one can climb in right it will
take them three minutes
anyway meanwhile suddenly there's a
fight in the audience
this my security disappear and then the
crowd start booing me
and the one thing i'm told by my lawyer
is don't ever
don't incite a riot you cannot say
anything inside right
and suddenly they stopped booing man i
go all right any of you
any of your facts i want to have the
[ __ ] kicked out of you
come in here right now anyway i knew no
one could get into the cage
why do you think you did that because
you said this is going to be funny like
even though i'm
going to be dead this is going to be so
funny at some point you don't think at
that point right
at some point i tell you what you get so
deep into character
that you kind of lost you get lost i got
lost and it was the most stupid thing
obviously do you think you'll ever go
out and risk your life like that again
i would love to do it again i don't want
to risk my life you know
and you know even when i was risking my
life i was always
very calculated you know right you don't
look at it as risking your life
i i was always trying to minimize the
risk so
for example you know when you go in a
room with was it ron paul who you
started coming on to
yes has anyone ever told you you look
like enrique iglesias
um you figured hey you could take him he
can't get you up right yeah
that's calculated yeah but it's you know
so for example if we were going into a
redneck bar i'd find out you know from
my security i'd go
what percentage of people have guns and
then
you know you try and take you know you'd
have the sound guy
you know touch them a little bit and see
if they had guns is that true
yeah you do that you try to size up the
room to see if people have guns yeah you
try and find out
the problem is in the sound you can't
you can't take people's guns off them
it's like
asking a guy to remove his underpants
whatever i remember we did one scene
where
it was a bunch of hunters in arkansas
again arkansas was a great player
it was crazy where you're in the tent
and you try to get into you sneak into
their tent naked yeah exactly so
and they're like going to kill you yeah
and so i said my security guard i go
you know with bruno we had to use
security before that we never used
security
and i just said all right take their
guns off them and i go the gun's off and
he goes no they
they won't take their guns out so i said
all right fine so
you know we're around the campfire look
at the far faster we are so
likes of saxons and city girls
oh no we aren't either and uh
they basically realized i was gay right
right and
they got really fidgety and one of them
they basically go off and they got their
guns
and they loaded their guns we're in a
dark field in the middle of
arkansas yeah and they've got loaded
guns i'm sitting in
sitting around a campfire and i know
them and i know that the next scene is
i'm gonna go in
naked into their tent and they've got
guns they're
loaded so it's you know it gets nervous
insane
and you ever said you never did your
wife i shouldn't do that
well you're there you know then you go
you're going should i continue to go
listen i'm here
i'm in arkansas i'm naked well i'm naked
yeah let's go and do it
yeah i've got some i've got the sex from
the city box set can i
just come in
you